string theorists often say that's not
how science works and I'm the concern
about string theory is that string
theory works like no other science is is
that this Theory plays by sociological
and and economically different rules if
you say for example that there's no
experimental uh test of string theory
yet many string theorists told us
exactly where we would find relatively
low energy super symmetry at the LHC
which failed to materialize and so you
can play infinitely the energy dog my
energy homework uh the particles are
never found if you push string theorists
hard enough they will say well it's
actually not a theory but a framework
and there is no reciprocal interest
because this community secretly thinks
that it is smarter than the other
communities and in general this is in
fact true I'm not arguing that what I am
claiming is that that level of
intelligence has been
misspent